Oh everyone thanks for coming
my name is Eugenia I lead the growth
team within Android enterprise that's
basically everyone who's out in the
field helping partners and customers
like yourselves be successful with
Android in the enterprise space with me
today is nisha sharma who's with
Accenture and we're here to talk to you
a little bit about how Android
Enterprise is disrupting the enterprise
space with mobility there's always a
good and bad about being in the latter
half of a conference the bad part
obviously is you've sort of absorbed a
lot of this information and you want to
be in the front because you have a lot
of energy when you're coming into the
conference and you're taking a lot of
notes and then you get to the back after
like overloaded but but the good news is
honestly as you're now processing all
the things you've heard about for the
last two or three days and incorporating
that into what you're supposed to be
doing back at the office
you're now realizing oh I got to go back
and how am I supposed to use all these
things in the priorities that I had set
just like two months ago at the
beginning of the year and and this is
really good context for us to talk about
Android Enterprise because a lot of
folks are thinking about mobility not as
a standalone thing but in the context of
what you're trying to do more broadly
within your business and it's not
surprisingly when we go and talk to
organizations a lot of organizations are
well on their way of deploying what they
would term is like digital
transformation technologies however when
you think about that more broadly in the
context of the capabilities of the
organization you begin to run into a lot
of problems and and I know when you hear
about more broadly within the conference
a lot of that are kind of on-premise
technologies versus cloud and things
like that but even more core to this is
the ability to deliver a lot of these
capabilities through mobility and when
you think about the fact that 41% of the
organization's don't have wall-to-wall
mobility that's kind of a problem right
when you think about IOT when you think
about the new things from analytics the
ability to have that knowledge at the
edge of your workforce and with your
customers is incredibly important the
idea that you have
to manage supply chain that you have to
manage intelligence without having an
endpoint out there of some type from a
mobility perspective makes it very
difficult for you to both build
applications and be successful in your
business because at this point mobility
or even web technologies they're just a
thin veneer to your business
they are the interface for both your
customers and your employees to access
all the capabilities that you've been
building within your organization
mobility is actually how people take
action it's how people will then
leverage those capabilities you've built
that you've built on GCP you've built on
your on-premise technologies all of
these things are our capabilities that
you need an actual device to then get
access to and so an example of this is
smart manufacturing or more broadly
speaking just distribution channels and
this affects retail customers this
affects manufacturing customers it
affects all the folks in industrial an
example specifically for us Marks and
Spencers our customer of ours that
facing this challenge as well in that
you have to manage your supply chain as
I talked about before but if your folks
in the field your task workers your your
people who are out actually in the
distribution centers don't have a mobile
device as part of your platform you have
a challenge right if they can't scan the
barcode if you can't get real-time
inventory information you have
difficulty and people are trying to find
ways around this with RFID and other
capabilities with sensors but ultimately
you have to have your workers be enabled
so so the question then becomes why
haven't we done this before everyone
kind of intuitively understands that in
order for me to be effective I need a
very mobile workforce and I need
everyone in my organization to be mobile
capable however what ends up happening
is you you slip you select a subset of
your organization to have these
capabilities you say oh the folks at
headquarters the knowledge workers the
c-level folks these are the people who
really really need to have this and what
ends up happening is you have this
isolated group that has mobile
capabilities but when they try to take
action against it you're limited in your
toolset you don't have the ability to
actually communicate this to the people
who are doing the work who are out in
the field and you end up in a situation
where you're challenged and and so so
it's not it's not like people don't want
to do this they're limited and and you
think about why we think quite a bit
about why why hasn't this proliferated
and that the answers aren't surprising
right it's security its manageability
its cost these are all the reasons why
as much as I'd love to have the person
who's checking the meter out in the
field have this technology Wow I don't
really have a good scalable way by which
to manage this so we spent a ton of
energy here at Google trying to help
think through that so that you don't
have this challenge you actually have
the tools necessary to leverage the
capabilities that you've heard about for
the last few days and this is a
conversation that you hear about quite a
bit with almost any enterprise software
right you think about the organ the
constituents within your organization
that you need to get over the line in
order to to actually be successful
there's IT there's your line of business
and there's your employee I think it
varies depending on the type of
technology you're talking about the
level of control the level of desire of
each organization to push forward that
technology but these are all incredibly
important constituents and and
historically a lot of folks have thought
about this is the the tug of war right
and I have to make this trade-off I'll
give you a very specific example
security so IT obviously wants an
incredibly lockdown environment because
they don't want any data leakage they
don't want any compromise within that
ecosystem however the end user doesn't
want that lockdown I personally have had
this experience I'm sure some of you has
well you get a device it is so
incredibly locked down that you can't
actually use it you shove it in your
drawer and then you actually have shadow
IT right you have a problem where people
are bringing their own device in their
own services and they circumvent that
control that you thought was so
fantastic so beyond that when you think
even beyond that to the line of business
you think about the the person who's
leading marketing the person who's
leading distribution and supply chain
someone who actually then has to to
manage that if that organization is so
locked down and their employees aren't
using that mobile device their
application actually isn't successful
right if you're in a very concrete
example if you have Salesforce and
nobody is updating it because the only
way you can access it is this
purpose-built device that no one wants
to use that tool isn't actually useful
for you so so what we think about that
is how do I help security be top of mind
but yet allow the end user and line of
business the flexibility to leverage
that platform so we when we think about
that we came up with the work profile so
rather than have a very binary choices
to lock down your device or not we
partitioned the device into a work set
of applications and experiences and then
you have a personal set of experiences
and what that allows you to do then is
rather than have two separate devices of
which maybe I have work applications on
my personal device and personal
applications my work device or I don't
use the work device at all I'm now in a
situation where I have this one device
where I have comfort in knowing that IT
is not monitoring my personal use and
yet I have a very secure container
within the phone that IT is very
comfortable then deploying very specific
work applications that don't bleed data
back and forth between the two profiles
so that is an example that that when we
fundamentally think bottoms up at Google
of how to solve the problem of
proliferating mobility throughout your
enterprise we actually designed the
solution to meet that need versus trying
to work our way back from a feature set
so this applies across all the needs
that when you think when we think about
a IT organization trying to think
through security and management and we
think about employees thinking about
privacy and well-being and we think
about lines of business that actually
want to ensure that they have a platform
under which they can be successful with
their transformation we focus on all of
these things and in order for us to do
that we we think both about the
ecosystem as well as the thing that
Google controls so the ecosystem for
Google we're very much about an open
ecosystem consistent for a Mandarin
enterprises to all the technologies that
you've heard about over the past week
however we understand that there are
minimum needs that that we need
consistency around in order to ensure
that the base level concerns that the
enterprise has are met and so we think
through Google Play we think through
hardware we think through the operating
system and the ecosystem can customize
around that but there are very core
components that don't compromise
security when you try to deploy this
within the enterprise what this allows
us to do is you now have security you
now have a flexible platform but you
also have a
variety of form factors to again think
through all of the needs of your
organization if you're trying to deploy
mobility across your organization if you
think you have a mining platform out in
the Bering Sea you can't use a very high
high cost device that's very fragile it
just doesn't work however you want that
to be part of your platform when you
have knowledge workers in your
organization you don't want to have
islands of devices that you're managing
separately so when we think about the
platform and the ability to you to go
end-to-end from smartphones and
knowledge workers out to signage a
point-of-sale system out to virtual
reality that allows an organization to
actually deploy once think through the
entire platform and actually build on
top of it and we've then on when you
have that we're able to unlock the a lot
of the tools that you've been hearing
about again in the in the past week you
now are able to leverage ml you're now
able to leverage development tools that
allow you to cross operating systems
these are all things that we want to
ensure your ability to do because we
know you have a very diverse set of
needs and it's not just about one tool
one device one platform we also think
through this too to ensure that we want
you to have a very seamless experience
when you deploy this even though we have
minimum consistency from a a security
perspective we also want to ensure that
when you're going out and going into the
ecosystem to procure the devices to
procure services we want to make sure
that you feel comfortable that they
actually understand that your enterprise
and can help you be successful so we
develop a program called Android
enterprise recommended that begins to
span that value chain you now know when
you go purchase a device it's
recommended it's certified by Google you
now know that when you go into an EMM or
a uem we've also certified that as well
so all the controls are security that we
talked about are now leverageable by you
as an organization through these tools
that we've reviewed and partnered with
quite closely within the ecosystem so
now when you purchase and you try to
think through an end-to-end solution you
now have certification across the entire
ecosystem so that you don't have to
worry about validating that within your
own organization so with that I want to
I want to introduce Nisha she's thought
through
of these situations in her experience
with Accenture we are now what we've
talked about quite a bit now or things
that have been happening in the recent
past as well as what people are going
through today obviously in her role at
Accenture she now is able to think
through things even beyond that think
through things what what happens in a
world when you go beyond just having
mobility and you go beyond just cloud
computing how does this actually
transform the business and the world
that we live in we we we want to be sure
that you actually have an understanding
of that so you can contextualize the
broad as well as the near-term thank you
very much
Thanks hi everyone I'm Neha Sharma I'm a
managing director at Accenture Digital
I've actually been at Accenture for
about 20 years now and about 15 over
those years have been in the enterprise
mobility space so the very early days of
mobile which I'm sure many of you can
can remember so it's been quite
fascinating to see how mobility has
changed over the course of this time and
what I wanted to do was spend some time
talking to you about what's next right
what are the trends that we are seeing
within technology within our solutions
and and you know the kind of work that
we're doing with our clients now so
every year
Accenture releases our our technology
vision we just released our most recent
2020 19 tech vision in February and the
technician talks about again like what
are some of the trends that we are
seeing in the business not just
technology trends but you know trends
that are impacting that again the kind
of work that our clients are doing and
so you know I thought I'd spend a little
bit of time sharing that with you so you
can understand where mobility fits where
Android fits and and the kinds of things
that we are doing in this in this space
because it's it's changing quite quickly
and and and you'll see that so just to
kind of you know set the stage I mean
you know the digital tech era technology
that we've been talking about all this
time it's expected now from every
business right in fact in in 2018
companies spent one point one trillion
dollars on digital transfer
projects and 94% of organizations say
that they're doing digital
transformation work already right so you
know it's just expected so what's next
right if everybody's doing this what
what are the next types of things that
we're working on and we call this now
the post digital era right and again you
know the digital technologies it doesn't
mean that digital is over it's certainly
not the case it just means that digital
is just expected to be there it's the
price of admission right you you know we
you know we don't say anymore you know
we don't ask well if you have a mobile
phone then do this right it's just on
your mobile phone do this right so is
this it's just assumed that that you
have this so you know we're starting to
see a new set of characteristics that
are defining what this post digital era
looks like and some of those things are
around individualization as an example
you know it's it's about knowing what
our users want right not just you know
it's it's not just personalization but
it's it's almost hyper personalization
it's knowing you know it's not just okay
I know you like these things or you know
you kind of you know done things around
this but it's it's really understanding
what you want and what you need it's
also around instant on demand right so
yeah okay we know what you want but you
want it now right you need it now so how
do we how do we get these services to
you in that way we also talked about
momentary markets how it's almost like
this pop up like an environment and I'll
give you this example of some work that
we've been doing with Carnival Cruise
Lines you know they they're transforming
the entire ship experience right and I
don't know if anybody's been on a recent
Carnival Cruise experience but what
they're doing now is everybody gets a
medallion they call it's a wearable
device so this medallion knows you know
it knows your preferences and knows
where you are on the ship it knows what
you're doing right and and all of that
and allows you to buy things right this
it's it's like that and in addition to
that they've got sensors all around the
ship the the cruise employees all have
you know mobile devices with them
and you know they've got all this
analytics and and everything just all
around the ship so the idea is that you
know if if let's say there's an
attraction you know like a show or
something and they realize that you know
based on everything that they know that
there's an upcoming attraction that
perhaps your child might be interested
in going and you know that you know that
they want to go to so now they can just
send you a message saying hey you know
I've reserved a spot for you would you
like to you know attend this right or
would you like to purchase this this
ticket you know to go right and it gives
you that opportunity so it's very
momentary right it's just you know hey
you weren't planning this but this
opportunity came up I'd like you to give
you the opportunity to to buy this and
then it's done right so that's what we
mean by momentary markets and and the
other and the other characteristic
characteristic is around trust and
responsibility we're just expecting
trust you know from all of our providers
right so much data is being collected
and being available about about us right
and so it's just expected that in this
new world that companies are treating
our data responsibly and you know and
kind of keeping - and making sure that
we understand also how they're using it
right so so what I want to do is take a
look at some of the trends that are in
the tech vision now there are five
trends that we talked about overall but
I'd like to really focus on three of
them because I think they are most
impacting the space around enterprise
mobility right and and it'll show you
what's happening in the enterprise world
some of the other trends are more around
the consumer experience and what we're
seeing in the consumer world but I
thought I'd start with them with the
enterprise side so the first trend is
called dark power dark with a cue and
and we'll go through each of these but
you know it's distributed Ledger's
artificial intelligence extended reality
and quantum computing these are
basically than the new wave of
technologies that we're seeing our our
clients use now right so the D is for
distributed Ledger's right we're using
technologies like blockchain and crypto
currencies and these types of things
we're using them in our supply chains to
you know end-to-end trusted trusted
transactions and such we have car makers
who are using blockchain type
technologies to protect cars from
hackers we have delivery companies like
DHL for example who are using blockchain
to ensure that you know perhaps some
medication that you ordered is the
correct medication and it's not
counterfeit and you know you're
following it along the way so you know
we're seeing the uses of those types of
technologies the a is for artificial
intelligence I'm sure you've seen so
many examples of some really cool
artificial intelligence and machine
learning types of implementations even
here at next in fact we have we have at
our at our booth we have the robot if
you if you've seen the robotic arm that
is taking petri dishes and putting them
under a camera for analysis and it's
using image recognition to to check the
quality of those samples and then it's a
it's got the new IOT edge TPU
incorporated in that to accelerate that
kind of processing but you know so so
there's a lot that's happening in the AI
space around image recognition natural
language processing and and so on and so
on in fact I think 67 percent of
businesses say that they're already
exploring artificial intelligence in
some ways today the r is for extended
reality XR we that's augmented reality
virtual reality mixed realities assisted
reality so on and so on and this is all
about new experiences it's about new
ways of training right we're now
providing our workers with you know
headsets that allow them to you know
virtualize environments so that they can
train and learn and in those places you
know as an example new ways of shopping
I'm sure you've seen right I mean you
know you take your phone and you can
augment some you know product that's out
there or be able to interact with some
product perhaps in a virtual way new
ways of exploring places right for
education and and so on just to be able
to virtual virtual EC and
a national park or a museum or you know
someplace like that then the Q is for
quantum computing we you know it seems
like quantum computing is far out but we
actually are working with with some of
our clients now to explore how quantum
computing can be used to solve some
difficult problems that they perhaps
weren't able to solve before you know we
worked with a company called one qubit
if you're familiar with them but we
mapped out over 150 different use cases
for quantum computing things like drug
discovery or route optimization or fraud
detection and those types of scenarios
so you know individually these are
definitely opportunities for
differentiation in this new world and
then when you put them together you
really really start to see some new and
even unimaginable ities around you know
what we can do in the future so you know
I talked about the future and these are
not way out future trends right these
are actually already happening now 89%
of businesses say that they're already
experimenting with one or more of these
types of dark technologies and
businesses are expecting big impacts
from these technologies just as an
example
41% of executives rank AI as the
technology that they expect to have the
most impact in their organization over
the next three years so people are doing
this and and it's happening now but
again like I said that doesn't mean that
everything we've done with you know the
digital technologies is done in fact we
were expecting that those are the
foundation for these new technologies so
you know we talked about here this this
move from smack to dark we all heard of
smack right as social mobile analytics
and cloud technologies and up until now
right that's that's the kind of work we
had been doing we had been using social
media technologies we've been rolling
out mobile devices you know maybe not
those 41% of companies that you
mentioned Eugene but but you know
companies really are
using these both in the consumer space
but also in the in the enterprise space
and then and then cloud and analytics
and you know it just says again as an
example right as we move to these dark
technologies mobile is just you know
it's the front end it's the channel that
people will be using it's just expected
to be there and well we'll talk about
that as well again just another example
that you know 92% of companies there say
that you know they're SMAC technologies
are still considered to be a competitive
differentiation but we are moving past
that and establishing that as a
foundation and it's only going to allow
us to take our future our businesses in
the future and the whole idea really is
that if you're not doing these you know
if you haven't already done the smack
technologies it it's going to be harder
for you to keep up right especially as
we're moving very very quickly into the
future as we all know the pace of
innovation the pace of technology
changes is just continuing to accelerate
all the time so just using the the
mobility example here right so we talked
about X our extended reality and this
example is just showing that you know
virtual reality and augmented reality
solutions are all built on mobile
devices right you you need a mobile
device you need the network
communication you need you know to have
applications that are built to support
this and they're all running on mobile
devices just as an example so the next
thing I want to talk about is what we
call human plus so again talking about
what is impacting our enterprises well
this is about our workforce and what
we're saying is that you know 90 percent
of jobs that we currently have today we
know that they're going to change as a
result of AI robotics and and other such
technologies right so jobs are changing
fast and what we're seeing is that you
know I mean we know is that individuals
as
workers right it's we of course come
with our skills and with our knowledge
but we are also becoming human plus and
that we are you know enabled even
further by technology that our companies
are providing to us to do our work right
and you know as as and I'll show you a
couple of examples of that but the point
is that as this workforce evolves our
companies need to keep up with that and
be able to provide the employees with
the tools that they want and need in
order to do their their jobs so a couple
of examples here that are just to
highlight you know we have an oil and
gas company whose workers right now have
mobile devices and mobile technologies
to help them troubleshoot issues that
are a mile underground with these new
game-like visualization tools that have
been developed for them to do that
troubleshooting right we have factories
where humans and work and and robots are
working side by side in you know in in
the factories to do the work and we have
AI tools that are helping to identify
which types of jobs should be done by
which types of workers we have workers
who are being trained as drone delivery
pilots right these are jobs that never
existed before but again they would they
would be able to use the technology and
and the applications and such that their
workers have that their employers have
given them to be able to work with these
drones and analyze what's coming from
them and and be able to you know to
support the the work in those ways but
you know when it when it comes to what
companies need to be thinking about in
order to support their workers we're
really looking at three areas and these
are around hiring training and knowledge
management so if you think about it went
from hiring right in in when it comes to
these these changing jobs is changing
workforce it's getting harder and harder
to find the people who have these skills
already right and so you know and and
it's up and so companies are shifting
the way that they normally
you know that the normal approaches that
they would use to hire people so they're
moving away from these more kind of
reactive skills based hiring approaches
right not just okay putting out a job
description that says I need someone who
has you know three years of accounting
experience right they're not looking at
it that way anymore now as an example
Unilever you know one of the things that
they're doing is they're actually
screening candidates with a series of
games so imagine they've got you know
these apps and and such that have these
games on them and they're assessing
their memory they're assessing their
acceptance of risk they're looking at
whether they're more likely to read
contextual or emotional cues right so
they're trying to understand how you
work rather than what you know and then
they're not using AI tools to review
those results and match these candidates
with open open jobs right so again
another example of you know we're
providing applications on mobile devices
to allow the employers to to do these
sorts of assessments on the training
side again companies can't hire fast
enough in you know in terms of the kinds
of jobs that we need skills for and so
there's a need to invest in rescaling
and providing on-demand training
opportunities for for our existing
workforce right there the the survey
says that 43% of businesses say that 60%
of their workforce will move into new
roles over the next three years so how
do we provide our workers with the
training that they need and this is
again being done with mobile because
they're on the go they're you know just
moving and we're really finding new ways
of providing training options to to our
employees and the in the third areas
around knowledge management so we have
more information available to us than we
ever have before but it's harder and
harder to find and access this
information right because people are
moving around quickly and and you know
it's just hard to capture so we're using
new technologies like natural language
processing as a way to capture this
information and be able to access it
we're usually looking at you know things
like indexing unstructured data
unstructured documents such as like an
incident
port or something like that so we can
you know you find find the information
we need there we're looking at knowledge
graphs to be able to search a wide
variety of you know the data sources
right and so again we're we're looking
we're looking at really changing our
tools that we've been using for so long
to be able to use them in new ways so I
think another point as well I think when
it comes to hiring and training one of
the things that businesses are also
looking at is that is the new generation
of workers right that are coming into
the workforce they're being forced to
look at what are the tools and
technologies that they're already using
in the world right and recognizing you
know in our world today the majority of
people have Android devices right and so
companies are looking ok well let's take
advantage of that let's build on these
Android experiences and in the Android
devices that they have to be able to you
know to provide them with the same types
of experiences that they're used to or
even tools like gee sweet right we're
you know I'm sure you've seen that in in
schools and colleges students are using
gee sweet so how do we build these new
you know these new tools and
capabilities on things that they already
know and they're comfortable with and
they like rather than thinking of Oh
what are those kind of you know the old
school kind of more traditional tools
they really have to think about these in
new ways so the third trend that I
wanted to talk about is secure us to
secure me this is all about security and
the point here is that security is no
longer just about protecting one's self
it's about protecting everyone right and
we can't as a business write a business
it still typically sees cyber security
as an individual effort
meaning that you know if I secure my own
systems if I secure my own you
data then I'll be safe but that's really
not the case because as businesses we
are part of a broader ecosystem now of
technology partners that we're working
with and every every technology every
solution every application no matter
where it's coming from you know can be
exposed to two vulnerabilities in some
way right so you can't just assume that
okay well you know you guys have it
covered or you have to work together in
this new world to do that in fact the
the survey point there says that only
29% of executives actually know that
their ecosystem partners are working
just as diligently as they they would
expect to in regards to security now
we're seeing new types of risks or
coming up coming up in new ways right so
around the whole misuse of data normally
we think that if someone has gets
unauthorized access to my data well then
they're gonna use that to exploit
something in my system but in reality
what's happening is you can find this
data you can find data in some other
system right that's totally unrelated to
you but use it somehow to you know to
infiltrate or get into your your own
systems right so these you know the
attackers are really now seeing this
ecosystem as an ever-widening attack
surface another example is around
aggregated data we think of aggregated
data as being someone anonymized or you
know can't necessarily tell who you know
identify individuals or something like
that but we've seen cases where there
was an example of some aggregated data
that was found on Strava and then used
that of contacts to identify - identify
some secret US military sites right so
you know in in today's connected an
ecosystem world the impact of cyber
attacks is just being exponentially
amplified and you know if you you might
remember the the wanna cry crypto worm
that that happened right that was where
someone you know exposed an operating
system vulnerability and attacked
300,000 computers over a hundred and
fifty countries in just a few days right
and that brought down all sorts of
businesses and impacted our work you
know tremendously right there was a the
Murai malware right that it it
hijacked a hundred thousand i OT devices
and then they use that to launch an
attack on a domain registration services
provider right so you know there's
there's these downstream impacts and all
sorts of you know impacts that we have
as a result of us being in this world
and you know what what i think
businesses are realizing is that as they
collaborate with their ecosystem
partners on new services and new
products and new experiences they also
really need to be collaborating on
security as well and there's no doubt
that Google with Android and and Google
cloud are a part of this right because
we all you know the foundation of a lot
of what we do is in on our mobile device
right and as as employees as consumers
like we don't we don't necessarily know
exactly where something went wrong right
we just you know it's like oh something
happened on my phone and people will
just think of you know okay it's an
Android problem whatever but but that's
why Google and and the Android
Enterprise team have been doing so much
to try to protect the experience on the
phones not just you know I have to
protect my piece here but recognize
their role in this ecosystem and in the
solutions that we're providing to
everyone and doing what they can to to
protect to protect us right again to
protect everyone not just as individuals
so so yeah so I think these are just
some of the ends that I wanted to
highlight for you to give you a glimpse
of you know what what's happening out
there is you think about the future and
how we can use continue to use mobile
and how it is such a foundation for what
we are doing these are the the other
trends here if you want to learn more
you can visit our site eccentric comm
slash technology vision but yeah
hopefully that helps so Eugene thank you
[Music]